how's it going man my name
Miss welcome back to some what up what
are you
doing what is that another one where
they coming from B that's how I roll
another
one [__] you look like an [__]
seriously is there
more going in here you guys suck Mar
bastic show all passages out of the only
way through is by traversing the
echanical subst with rout activating the
system will get you a direct route but
it's dangerous extending the service
Bridges is safer but the Sy oh I did it
oh my God all right what yeah whoa what
was that I heard something ah whatever
sure it's nothing oh here we go go it
yeah
oh should I go there yep I
should is that all you got
barrels what is this oh armor shards all
right uh
stop what what what did you do say where
you come from demon spawn not now I'm
trying to computer not now it even spawn
stupid [__] all right ah
yam you demon F not what I'm walking all
right now this door should be open it
is what thought I saw someone all right
got to jump
again
no oh I'm back what
happened oh
no [__] this game sometimes [__] jumping
they always make you jump
always shut shut up lady all right bam I
see you in a couple second bro right we
dealt with the demon SPS finally we can
do this all
right don't [__] with me now don't don't
don't don't I'm
ready I did it elevated the night you
[__]
you stop only I can shoot you he doesn't
know the rules
what are you doing didn't I tell you one
second ago stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop who's shooting me holy [__]
stop
stop where are you hey how you doing
what's your name cool very
cool oh no more demon spawns Bang
that's how I kill I just bam your ass
all right there's got to be another one
the door isn't open yet bring it to me
demon
spawns I'm rich demon
spawns oh this is where I died the last
time I think
so why isn't he opening the door come on
demon SPS you're better than this demon
sponds demon
Bond oh maybe bug itself here I think
he's supposed to come here throw a Nate
over
there they don't work oh okay okay who I
regret this decision H don't kill me
please I don't want to become a
box oh we're good should we go over
there over there
please what what oh better go here ooh
oh no no no no
yes what oh my God jumping skills oh no
I don't have jumping skills what what
Crouch don't chop me all right holy [__]
we made it go forward
please ah it's difficult as
hell oh
yeah down we're going okay fine with me
we're going here I hear
spiders you're not a
spider there you are all
right ah another
one all right initiate magnetic field
discharge why not what what
what what the hell am I doing
what you see this [__] spider sence
something you can't
do stupid spider you can't do science oh
okay I can jump here
now what did
one ah spiders can't jump ah
no spiders can't jump but just can jump
that's fine I got a quick save I hope
maybe probably not
ah no not again they spun when I
I got to kill that Spider Man all right
Bros I'm sorry let's kill the spider
spider you're not supposed to be here
spider
what ah so sick of jumping right now
every [__] thing I play these days
you got to jump and
[__] oh stay there ow ow it burn it
burn stop stop you're killing me over
here
ow [__]
off all right give me that
Health about like a let's go whoa let's
knock what the hell is up with this room
oh no this is
scary
hello okay okay we're good what how did
I what what
what it's going to be shoot the
barrels that's how I roll [__]
shooting all the barrels that's my
application what is
yours a [__] I shot it too early wa nice
what are you
doing stop pretending you're a
shadow stupid so all
this how do you become so evil is this
because you're bald huh is that why
you're evil probably probably why he's
evil all right what do you want smack
you that's how I roll I smack my Victim
that's my mark of [__] slapping aha you
better believe it works every time oh
you got my tag [__] and now you're my
[__] technically you're not my [__]
anymore but that's okay
whoa whoa whoa I want that toy give me
that toy I want to kill people
that what are you doing shut
up shut up shut up shut up sh uhoh uh-oh
what did I
do whoa cut scenes always scare me man
oh no we're going to caves and
[__] as no
buner what the [__] are
you
ah no it has TS [__] that
[__] what the
hell no no no no ow that
hurt ow what are you doing [__] EG
spiders shoot her in the tent shoot you
in the tent
what you going to do about it you ain't
got no tit girl what at this thing
ow stop throwing things at me
very why don't you just [__]
that no no I'm trapped I'm trapped I'm
trapped I'm trapped
oh oh I got to say something
badass guess she wasn't spider enough
that was the most stupid [__] ever all
right let's let's keep going stupid
spider girl I guess she
wasn't
Spiderman yeah I'm yes Alpha Labs holy
[__] progress this is where we were
going alpal Labs number
four doing pretty good this one Doom 3
is always a lot of fun to play I'm not
going to lie uh it's a fun game it's a
fun game it's fun times it's not really
that scary because you're focusing on
shooting people all the freaking time he
kind of takes it away from me move in
and take positions um I Heard it has
more scarier elements coming along like
this did you hear that doesn't give me
status always clear there's nothing here
Sam there is something there what the
hell Sam you should have covered your
bro
man a
no no don't shoot that it's very bad
thing to shoot oh it's a Star Wars final
seeing and [__] come on the Death Star
is
exploding
who okay what warning coolant Rod two
offline cool operation temperature
exceeding safe levels no Co bravo team
is down I don't
care K him PLO that's right PLO
his all right watch out for those
barrels I miss you man
who where are where is he kill the
batt that's right PLO they don't got
[__] on us man attention all person
evacu die back that's how we rolling
this
uh-oh
uh-oh uhoh
uhoh you're so stupid I got FL on my
side why don't you why fight
back dude don't why do you hi hi in
Corners
man so
stupid so
stupid so stupid
all right ow burn like Mr burn what the
hell give me a break here what the [__]
they're everywhere no not this situation
again not this situation again not this
situ all right we're good we're not good
we are [__] terrible we got it I got
this got to shoot don't stop me stop
slapping me holy [__] there's a lot of
fighting going on give me a break care
PLO you're supposed to be the one who's
fighting thank you PLO ah there's more
PLO don't hit
PLO the punishment for hitting PLO is
grounded for two
ow [__] [__] this place is
insane how many things do you want me to
kill tell me all right PLO hold me is
there someone over there PLO yep you're
never wrong are you
it's [__] creep for this place chill
chill chill
chill ow
blurter so dark God damn so many things
to
count what is
this report all injuries at once well
what about me what about me
man I'm an injury give me a break here
please this is
ridiculous shoot the
ble that's how I rob a [__] thank them
Pluto that's right ow what are you
want holy [__] so out of that
place all right I think we're good PLO
this is broken though
Pluto Pluto come here come here man H oh
you're going to Shield there aren't you
oh well it was nice fighting with you
Pluto that was war coolant Rod 2 offline
okay main reactor operation exceeding
safe
levels Pluto don't
cry Pluto it's
fine
whoa okay I think there is something
over
here oh I was right there was
something okay fla stop
crying is that a mad
crying
yay whoa help me with what no don't turn
into a
spider what the [__] happened there no
no bad thing oh flashlight work ah bad
bad head get back to your
place stupid ass House 1 2 3 ah son of a
[__] service bridge now
operational all right that was
disgusting anyway what no no stop B ow B
bat I want to end this episode here it's
out of my bed not y stop it stop ow you
pissing me up ow just got to come I'll
see you next episode when I smack this
[__] smack you that's right that's
right stay oh there's more of them son
of a [__] so out here a
[__] activate maintenance team locate
the entrance to Alpha Labs 4 what does
it say death is
coming you don't
know I guess it was right death is
coming